eli morgan the young right-hander the
rookie on the mound for cleveland
tonight
he's low 90s if he hit gets 93 that is
above his average his best pitch is a
change up those at about 20 a little
over 20 percent of the time i think he
needs to throw it a little more wayne
especially the right-handed hitters he's
also got a slider and a curveball
basically a five-pitch guy he's got more
of a straight fastball i think he should
pitch up and he's done that the first
three pitches here swung on and missed
strength three anderson chasing the high
fastball so a four pitch strikeout
louise robert 24 years old he has all
the makings
of a future mvp
he's going to get out right here though
andres jimenez retires robert
this one easy for bradley zimmer and eli
morgan goes through the top three in the
white sox lineup with a one two three
inning lancelin
the ace of the white sox staff guy who
very well could be and should be the
game one starter in the american league
division series and
like many of these white sox aj a guy
that's trying to prove that he's healthy
and ready for october
anderson couldn't reach it
straw thinking about second base and
he'll make it
anderson
moving toward third with a backhand and
the ball trickled right under his glove
it was sharply hit and a hustle double
for mile straw lancelin has to face jose
ramirez in an rvi situation he is the
one guy
for the indians you don't want to face
in these situations the incredible jose
ramirez steve lynn challenges him here
he tries to get him on the cutter
that's driven to deep right center jose
ramirez gets lance lynn again
jose ramirez
home run number 36.
98 rbis two nothing tribe
lance lynn with the high fastball to
strikeout bradley but jose ramirez got
the best of lynn blank socks have
runners and first and second with nobody
out
of goes the other way
that's harold ramirez on the warning
track to make the catch now the o2
swing and a missed change up he got
garcia for out number two strikeout
number two
jimenez tried to get the odd at second
gets the out at first instead
and eli morgan works out of trouble two
on nobody out in the white sox don't
score
andre simenas batting 206 four homers 13
rbis
just 23 years old it's this ball deep to
right garcia watches it go andres
jimenez with a line drive blast to right
his fifth home run and the indians have
hit two home runs off lance lim
and lead three-nothing here in the third
inning
nasty from lance lynn
a little revenge after the home run
this guy keeps going out there and he'll
have the occasional rough start most of
his starts have been solid here's his
one-two swing and a missed strength
three got him with the change up
abreu's down on strikes for the first
out in the inning here's the 1-0
swung on there's a chopper to the second
baseman jimenez flips onto first and he
throws out jimenez to retire the side in
order morgan continues to roll he's held
the sox hitless
through four
a little bloop shot and that's why no
hitters are tough to throw monkata
trying for second and a white sox first
hit is a double
first base hit there's the start
there's a strikeout for eli morgan on a
changeup
[Music]
there goes straw rosario does swing
anderson will have to hurry and he's not
able to get rosaria
so the indians using their speed at the
top of the order
infield singles from straw and rosario
and cleveland with two on
here's jose ramirez two run homer to
right center and a strikeout
switch hitter manning left-handed
hernandez can't get it it's a base hit
for ramirez straw comes home to score
four nothing indians
ramirez
with his third rbi
you might have got a piece of lane and
almost got a piece of ramirez either way
it's in the center field it's a base hit
for front meal reyes it scores rosario
and lance lynn's having a tough night
he's allowed five runs as the indians
have opened up a pretty sizable lead
fly ball plenty deep enough to score
jose ramirez
bobby bradley gets an rbi with the
sacrifice flying cleveland has a six
nothing lead
oh there's a drive off the bat of mile
straw
running out of room and he leaps and he
makes a catch right up against the wall
and left
hernandez hits and it could be a double
play ball rosario and jimenez turn it
over to bradley
6-4-3
more than a walk per inning more than
two strikeouts per inning for burr
tried to kick save that one off the bat
of rosario but instead it's another hit
for cleveland
rosario's had a couple of them
and he's on to begin the bottom of the
eighth
that's how you find a guy like jose
ramirez
burr strikes him out
ramirez caught looking and there's one
end
all right fastball takes care of the
fragile back-to-back strikeouts for burr
brian burr is just raring back and
throwing it by these guys
good inning for ryan burke three
straight strikeouts after the lead off
hit by rosario
go to the ninth in cleveland 6-0
the pit swung on whacked high and fairly
deep to left but harold ramirez retires
luis robert out number one
diving effort but jivanes couldn't reach
it that's a base hit for abreu
only the third hit in this game for the
white sox
here's the 1-1
swinging a chopper into the shift second
baseman jimenez to second one relay to
first double play bogey